Nintendo's 3ds handheld family is deep
into its lifecycle and with so many
versions already released combined with
the high demand for the switch you may
be wondering where another 3ds model
fits in well with the new 2d s XL not
only will newcomers get access to its
vast library of games but we get the
best design version of this dedicated
handheld the original 2d s is an
entry-level version with its slate like
design and omission of audio
stereoscopic 3d now with the new 2d s XL
which retails for 150 bucks we have many
of the features that make the new 3ds XL
great larger screens stronger processor
and the c-stick and z LZ are buttons all
while being about two and a half ounces
lighter the new 2d s XL also adopts the
clamshell design of 3ds systems but
improved upon it it's slightly shorter
and a near-perfect seal is created
around the two halves when it's closed
this is due to how the two screens are
seated the bottom screen doesn't
protrude as with every other clamshell
based 3ds and the top screen has a sleek
smartphone like build the chassis sports
a matte finish which makes for better
grip and tops off the system simple
elegant look and every 3ds I've used the
hinge seems to feel a little loose
causing the top portion to wobble back
and forth if you gave it a little shake
unfortunately the same holds true for
the 2d s XL it's as if the top is
loosely screwed into the hinge this
gives a bit of a fragile feel to an
otherwise solidly built system as you
can tell from the name the 2d s XL
ditches the 3d capabilities but it isn't
essential to play any of the system's
games as it doesn't serve a gameplay
function since this is an XL model it's
equipped with a 3ds XL size displays a 4
point 9 inch screen up top and a 4.2
inch resistive touch screen on the
bottom both screens are well over an
inch bigger than those of the original
2d s however the 400 by 240 and the 320
by 240 resolutions feel somewhat
antiquated in 2017 they're noticeably
low res compared to many other devices
but you can exactly blame the new 2d s
XL high res screens would also require
Hardware faster than the already
upgraded processor of the new DS systems
like the other DS systems with the new
moniker the 2d SXL is equipped with the
quad-core arm 11 CPU at 804 megahertz
and does provide that extra juice for
snappier navigation through the
operating systems and UI there are a
handful of games that actually require
the faster hardware like xenoblade
chronicles binding of issac and a bunch
of SNES games on Virtual Console many
notable games run better and load faster
such as Pokemon Sun and Moon Monster
Hunter generations and Super Smash Bros
for 3ds so while the screens look
pixelated it doesn't negate the fact
that the platform is home to a breadth
of amazing games still haven't played
bravely default Fire Emblem awakening or
Zelda a link between worlds the time is
now the adoption of the c-stick means
you'll get superior camera controls and
additional functions in certain games
and while it looks and feel stiff the
c-stick accurately recognizes miniscule
movements the Circle Pad offers smooth
movement but it still doesn't match the
ergonomics of an actual analog stick
face buttons the d-pad and the triggers
all offer a solid tactile feel an NFC
reader is also built into the system so
you'll get support for all your amiibo
there are a few small changes compared
to the new 3ds XL the 2d s XL stereo
speakers are located at the bottom
corners of the body but at louder
volumes you'll notice that the sound
rattles the back end of the system which
makes it feel a little bit cheap the
front-facing camera is moved to the
hinge and the two forward facing cameras
move to the top of the backplate the
home button now sits below the d-pad and
the stylus is slightly shorter than the
previous three yes stylus along the
bottom of the system is the power button
and a 3.5 millimeter audio jack adjacent
to the stylus slot the enclosure that
houses the game cartridge and micro SD
card in particular is a noteworthy
improvement over the 3ds XL which how do
you take up a stubborn back place to
insert an SD card a 4 gigabyte Toshiba
micro SDHC card will already be inserted
with each new 2d s XL though you'll want
more storage capacity if you plan on
downloading your games one of the
biggest blunders of the new 3ds XL was
the absence of an AC adapter but don't
trip the new 2d s XL comes with the
charger when it comes to battery life
expect roughly three and a half to four
and a half hours of play time
I'm off a full charge I got
approximately three hours and 55 minutes
straight playing Zelda Ocarina of Time
with full brightness and Wi-Fi enabled
despite a few shortcomings there's a lot
to like about the new 2d SXL should you
consider buying one if you already have
a new 3ds XL probably not however if
you're still on one of the older DS
models or interested in jumping into the
expansive library of 3ds games I would
highly recommend you consider the new 2d
s XL the platform may be showing its age
but it's Nintendo's best vs system yet
are you thinking of getting a 2d s XL
tell us in the comments I know you liked
this video so give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to GameSpot for more tech and
game coverage thanks for watching